you are fresh off the stage an epic
performance how you feeling i'm feeling
good now i was like you know with all my
adrenaline now now we celebrate were you
nervous before hitting the stage
i always get nervous like the
first like 10 minutes before that
waiting yeah it's not nervous just
adrenaline you know but once i'm on
stage i'm like all right let's do it
you hit the stage you do your thing and
then you can enjoy the rest of the night
right how are you going to celebrate
oh we're celebrating with my with my
team you know uh my family through you
know face time
flying back home um i just finished my
tour so
after billboard i just want to take a
summer break you know we're gonna take a
little time to chill
to chill and just focus on my next
project you know
coming up
speaking of that album you recently said
that you and your girlfriend rosalia are
working on new music together now is
that easier or harder when you are
working
on music with the love of your life
i think it is
[Music]
both
uh easier and complicated
i want it this way well i want it that
way chile i mean i respect her a lot
she's a great musician and
we're just putting our ideas in
you know we're not gonna do it
now we're gonna be more focused in our
stuff
you know this year but probably next
year we're coming with a surprise for
you guys
will it be a love song i feel like that
for sure
i mean how can it not be right you know
it's obvious you know we
i mean we everything thought you know
everything is good you know i love it
been for a while and
no that's my girl that's my girl that's
love my life you know
i love that where is she tonight she's
flying back home she's in europe right
now and you know i'll see her now in
summer power couple problems that's what
it is
yep power couple problems one's flying
this way one's flying that way yeah it
was just we work our hot we work a lot
you know we just focus in our future and
it is what it is you know we enjoy the
the present the moment
and
you've got a lot to enjoy you have a new
track out with shakira too i mean
you are heading into the summer with
just such a special time in your life
with this new music how does it feel
especially working on a track with her
no it feels good um i just throw a few
collabs on
you know shakira with daddy yankees his
last album now bunny come okay it's just
a lot of music for summer and
you know i enjoy a lot doing the video
with jack
you know chakita is like a legend and
the dance she's a great dancer so i was
like oh i need to is she teaching you a
thing or two a little bit a little bit
but she was in the you know this robot
kind of buyer so i was like all right
check it out let's do it you can do this
so now we have fun we have fun and you
know i'm glad that i collab with her and
i'm happy that people love the song
you